hey was macht ihr denn hier ich wollte
mir gerade ein eis holen gehen auf
meinem fahrrad wir dann kommt doch
einfach mal mit und willkommen zu einer
neuen folge laufen und schlecken oder
wie wir sagen radeln oder cuisine krimi
kommt uns doch nicht ganz auf dem titel
einigen
[Musik]
unsere erste station auf dieser reise
ist die schokoladenmanufaktur in der
kasse kriegs in der kastellstraße die
schokoladen eis manufaktur ist das ganze
jahr über geöffnet
neben eis verkaufen sie auch pralinen
und jeden donnerstag brot natürlich
alles selbst gemacht ich habe mir zwei
kugeln genommen weil die sorten sogar
waren einmal rabattes ursanne und gurke
limette also die aushilfe laktose
unverträglichkeit ist da riesengroß was
ich schon mal mega gut fand anni hat
sich schwarze johannisbeere geholt jetzt
kommt der geschmacks ist oder das wird
auch einfach ein ganzes video sein in
dem ich einfach schlecht mein gott
also wenn man rhabarber schule feiert
dann feiert man das eis mega was mich
wirklich ganz besonders interessiert und
die autos hinter mir auch gurke limette
schmeckt sofres ich meine wie soll man
geschmäcker beschreiben geschmeckt hat
nach google limette das was der name
sagt davis probieren und schwarze
johannisbeere kann man auch einfach
nicht an ihm eine hammer toll
assistenten habe ich darauf hingewiesen
dass hier das letzte mal unbedingt ein
ranking haben wolltet also haben wir uns
für geschmack preis und auswahl
entschieden geschmack top 5 sterne
der preiskrieg schon ordentlich rein
allen euro 40 die kugel und wenn man
zwei nimmt dann kostet sie 1 eur 30 es
gibt so ein mengenrabatt aber man muss
auch sagen so ist handgemacht hier also
in dieser kleinen stube oder musik im
hintergrund machen wir haben ihn sogar
dabei beobachten können wir gerade
kirsch amarena macht vier von fünf
sterne für den drei und für die auswahl
auch vier von fünf mann hat zwar nicht
die crazy krassen sorten aber es gibt
schon mal eine auswahl mehr als schoko
vanille laktoseintoleranz fühlen sich
hier gut abgeholt und veganer auf zum
nächsten eisladen vom café kidz ging es
auf unseren bikes niedrig sein was quasi
gleich um die ecke liegt wir stehen hier
live auf dem boxhagener platz hinter mir
ist der boxhagener platz nächste station
heißt eispiraten habe ich noch nie was
von gehört
herzlich willkommen wir befinden uns
hier live hinter mir fährt ein
reinigungspersonal der berliner
verkehrsbetriebe keine ahnung die
eispiraten findet man seit 2010 in der
grünberger straße
sie bieten 32 verschiedene eissorten an
und sind bekannt dafür außergewöhnliche
kombinationen auszuprobieren
drinnen filmen wurde uns aber nicht
erlaubt was haben sie zu verbergen die
eispiraten das dreht ihr in der nächsten
folge von dem investigativen
journalismus den wir betreiben
wir haben uns wieder vegane sorten
ausgesucht weil ich auch irgendwie keine
laktose tabletten habt einmal blut
orange ingwer und birne
roter pfeffer aber irgendwie bei der
weiteren nicht so und nicht so
freundlich
da war nicht schokoladenmanufaktur schon
besser die kugel größen sind absolut
okay der preis ist wieder 140 jetzt muss
nur der geschmack überzeugen die auswahl
ist auch natürlich verrückt gewesen
roter pfeffer birne und irgendwann blut
das habe auch nicht überall thomas
apfelkuchen was kannst du noch gut von
marzipan dachte nach so massiv an boden
wurde auch von der community in poing
tatsächlich das schmeckt wie das weiße
von einer branche der spätere er meint
schmeckt also sehr sehr zuckrig kann er
auch in der birne liegen oder
pfefferkorn
das ist extra sie also crazy kombination
nicht ganz so mein favorit also
geschmacklich würde ich sagen
drei von fünf überzeugt mir nicht ganz
so preis 140 glaube wir werden überall
bei 140 liegen und die auswahl von fünf
also das war gut dass wir unser eis auf
muss auch stecken wo ist schon geil
ich liebe der larven runterladen ich mag
es 2017 eröffnete der lage einen kleinen
stand mit dem roller 2018 folgte dann
der erste laden in der kotterner straße
das beste an den lago die grundbasis vom
eis ist vegan und viele der toppings
auch hier hat man macht sondern wo sie
erst mal einige schmecke aussuchen und
habt ihr noch die soße aussuchen dann
kannst du doch clubbings aussuchen und
noch extras dazu ob du drei räumen wir
haben will ist alles egal also wie die
eissorten toppings natürlich dann nicht
und dann wird das da hinten gestartet
ihr habt bestimmt alle schon diese
eisfrei videos auf youtube gesehen aber
in echt macht das zugucken noch viel
mehr spaß es funktioniert so dass alle
zutaten auf einer extrem kalten platte
zerhackt werden und durch die kälte
friert dann die mischung so schnell dass
man sie glatt streichen und auf rollen
kann
und diese individuell zusammengestellten
röllchen kommen dann in ein becherchen
[Musik]
sponsern hier haben wir unsere rolle eis
mit streuseln drauf oreo kekse drin
vegane nutella weko alles dabei so neiße
konsistenz weil das so irgendwie hart
ist wo wir und die tories kommen die
gefunden
das ist halt auch das ding muss da
wirklich eine gute kombination findet
man kann sich das geschmacklich halt
echt sauer und vegan habe 520 stellen
was andererseits so eine kugel eis ist
sind ja von der masse her passt vier
kugeln oder 303 auf jeden fall dafür
dass es frisch zubereitet wird halt
alles handgemacht kannst es dir
individuell aussuchen schon geil ich
liebe die leute wenn ihr hier in der
ecke seit gibt zudem haben und
irgendwann könnte auch frucht als basis
nehmen
man kann auch was tierisch ausmachen und
das ranking bitte also ich mag ich bin
von 535 für die masse 520 ist okay ist
es ein extrem voller eisbecher da geht
ja sogar nach oben hin raus und überlegt
man was da alles drin ist auch lego ich
glaube 100 gramm wog ost unglaublich
drei euro oder so auswahl ja
riesenauswahl kannst dir deine eigene
kombination machen wie genau sie hier
schmeckt 55 alles
wir haben einen minuspunkt an diesem eis
entdeckt dieser behälter ist einfach zu
klein das schmilzt alles an einem vorbei
und das können wir besser meine hand ist
voller eiscreme werden schnell gegessen
meckern auf hohem niveau aber ihr erstes
date ist offen
nach großer besprechungen haben uns
jetzt entschieden heute schluss zu
machen
die lage hat uns gekillt wir haben uns
ein becher geteilt und es war viel viel
viel zu viel
also wir machen an einem anderen tag
weiter für euch ist das jetzt nur ein
schnitt also bis gleich
was macht ihr denn her
habt ihr lust auf noch mehr eisbären mit
als nächstes geht es zu wolke sieben in
der bahnhofstraße in friedrichshain wir
befinden uns nämlich immer noch in
friedrichshain woran erkennt man einen
guten eisladen an der polizei sei für
draußen
das besondere an wolke sieben sind diese
veganen baumstriezel oder krimis wie sie
sie auch nennen und da kommt das eis
dann rein und es sieht einfach über s7
zu den lodges aus und das will ich auch
unbedingt probieren der eisladen wolke
sieben hat dieses jahr in der
bahnhofstraße seine türen geöffnet
frei nach dem motto mehr ist mehr bieten
sie krasse eiskreationen aus
selbstgemachten waffeln an und wem das
noch nicht reicht der kann auch sein eis
zum beispiel aus einem mit so ner dessen
die verkäufer waren mega nett und
konnten uns ein veganes schimmlig
zusammenstellen
das ist frisch gebacken und wigan leute
also wir haben hier eine frischgebackene
selbstgemachte waffe die ist auch
wirklich richtig schön warm und sieht
übels knusprig aus the tales test leute
einige probieren es ist so lecker dass
new york hatte und jetzt noch jetzt
jetzt kommt die knaller front das geht
wohl rein
eigentlich machen sie es oft als oben
drauf wie veganer gibt es dann zwei
veganer eissorten sind sozusagen mir
ersten kurz und melden uns dann mit
einem review zurück aber es ist super
lecker man glaubt gar nicht das vegan
ist weil das so cremig wirkt das schoko
softeis ist super zart schokolade ich
aber nicht so schwer wie mit sahne
jetzt weiß man die waffe in die tiefe
und mein gott das nochmal urio der preis
gerechtfertigt sich weil das ist frisch
gebacken
das ist ein bisschen wie ein eisbecher
to go sondern eine waffe oder richtig
lecker die würfel wird sagen vier von
fünf der abzug ist das ist halt wirklich
und mehr kostet gerechtfertigt aber es
kostet viel auswahl die eissorten da
gibt es viele vegane und normale
eissorten jetzt nicht zu crazy aber das
gar nicht schlimm die haben auch sein
eigenes eis mit karamell und so das
hatte timo mal probiert das ist lecker
geschmack 5 und 5 natürlich was soll ich
denn sagen es ist köstlich
also wenn ihr in berlin seit in
friedrichshain probiert auf jeden fall
werke sehen aus wie geht's zum nächsten
mit vollem bauch machten sie sich auf
den weg zum nächsten laden der wirklich
nur um die ecke war hatten sie schon
appetit auf eine neue kugel eis nein
essen sie trotzdem eine klar jetzt
kommen wir zum highlight dieses videos
green
es gibt den laden ebenfalls seit diesem
jahr aber das motto ist hier ein wenig
anders
vegan nachhaltig eco friendly und das
leckerste vegane eis auf der ganzen welt
machen als wir den besitzern von unserem
test video erzählt haben waren sie super
happy und wollten uns alles über ihre
mission erzählen
das besondere an ihrem eis ist dass sie
nicht die klassischen ersatzprodukte
benutzen wie soja hafer mandel oder
kokos sondern ihre eigene caches
grundbasis herstellen alle zwei wochen
werden 20 kilogramm caches verarbeitet
und so kann es auch passieren dass sie
für sorten wie strawberry cheesecake ihr
tage brauchen bis das eis verkauft
werden kann
meine erwartung war also hoch sie haben
gesagt man wird nicht schmecken dass es
vegane syffus
machen wir ganz gut retten
wir haben wirklich nicht das wirklich
und eco friendly wird besonders groß
geschrieben sie arbeiten zb mit blende
pläne zusammen und für ihre zutaten
einkäufe sind sie auf e bikes unterwegs
wir möchten die eigentlich bezeichnet
wie haben sie die leistung okay wenn wir
haben sie denn nicht so hoch ist eine
gute geschichte ich glaube und ich sehe
euch hier ja kein gedanke ganz ehrlich
das war richtig richtig nett mit dem und
das alles schmeckt glaubt es mir richtig
lecker preis 180 pro kugel ist aber auch
verständlich es ist sehr sehr viel
arbeit
ihr habt gehört 4 tage brauchte
teilweise für eine sorte weil sie erst
mal die cash für mich selber machen
müssen und dann noch die eissorte machen
deswegen würde ich sagen für die quali
55 für den preis das zeigt auch die
polizei die auswahl kriegt von mir kind
von fünf bei matcha latte aber noch nie
gesehen feiere ich total fina vater war
lecker alles was wir probiert haben war
köstlich
deswegen gibt es auch für den geschmack
absoluter sieger an juni haben gerade
noch darüber geredet wie nett die
einfach gerade waren geht zu greens
kuchen holt euch eine schöne warme kugel
die restlich schmeckt perfekt besser
geht es gar nicht und wenn ihr da seid
und bei greens group eine kugel eis holt
dann sagt bitte irgendwie dass ihr ein
video gesehen habt und deswegen da seit
wir bei irgendeinem land und goldene
karte am 100 und mit dem ende meines
ices
gibt es ein sieg für uns ja nicht
erhältlichen netbooks und auch wollten
dass wir diese message nach draußen
tragen
das aber wird nicht selber machen zudem
hast du zwei kirchen laden kaufen alle
22 kilo kirschen aus chile wird einfach
nur zucker am ende können sie ja noch so
nett sein wie sie wollen das eis ist
wirklich köstlich alles so lecker und
vegan und jetzt geht es nach hause ich
hab euch das video gefallen ist es super
laune in berlin heute und wenn man
gerade drehen möchte und das bisschen
leiser haben will fällt es einem
besonders auf ihr könnt hier abonnieren
hier sind noch andere videos und kanäle
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder sagen tschüss ich jetzt auf
dieser baustelle ja ok
[Musik]